the two things that I did in my life
that I would say were the most impactful
was uh first
um learn how to meditate that gives me
um an Equanimity that helps a lot
and then
um thinking about principles that
whenever I would encounter something
most importantly painful things but
anything that I would
um reflect on realities that happened in
my interactions with it and then I would
write down the principle so I started to
do that also in the company because I
needed to communicate with other people
why am I doing it what is this crazy
place like and why are we doing that
that way so I want to encourage people
to do that that's also why I put out a
journal just recently A lot of people
asked me to uh
help them write their own principles so
I just put out a journal so that's those
are the things I really want to
encourage if people can I would
encourage meditation and I would also
encourage the writing down their
principles